Welcome, everybody, welcome.
Please enjoy yourself.
Welcome. Thank you.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy Friday, everyone.
[ Audience cheers ]
Now, let's get to
some news here.
Well, we've all gotten used to
wearing masks wherever we go,
but I just read that
the CDC is looking into
whether it's still necessary
to wear them outdoors.
-Oh?
-Ohh.
-That's all this country
needs right now --
Trevor,
the bartender from Señor Frog's,
to have been right all along.
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "I told you, bro!"
I guess this is good,
although I was kind of looking
forward to another summer
with bikini lines on my face,
you know?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Honestly,
it would be nice to get back to
when a masked man
outside your house
was just a serial killer,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, it's a big weekend
for Hollywood.
The 93rd annual Oscars
are this Sunday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Of course, in quarantine, even
the Oscar statue gained weight.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's gonna be a very
unique year for the Oscars.
There's no host, no after party,
and no movies anyone saw.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep, this year's Oscars
are about celebrating
all the movies
we scrolled through and thought,
"20 bucks? Nope."
[ Laughter ]
But this is interesting --
the Academy announced
that masks are not required
while cameras are rolling,
but should be worn
during commercial breaks.
-Huh?
-That makes sense.
-Yeah.
-If we've learned anything
about the virus,
it -- it only spreads
during commercials.
[ Laughter ]
And speaking of movies, today,
"Mortal Kombat" was released
in theaters and on HBO Max.
I haven't seen
the new "Mortal Kombat" yet,
but I think I speak
for everyone when I say
I just hope
it lives up to the play.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, check this out -- Netflix
is reportedly nearing a deal
on an upcoming biopic
about the band KISS,
called "Shout It Out Loud."
Yeah, it's pretty exciting news.
-[ Chuckling ]
Yeah, Jimmy, so exciting.
[ Light laughter ]
-Higgins, I didn't realize
you were such a big KISS fan.
-What? No, no, no.
I just love biopics.
[ Light laughter ]
-I-I see.
Did you know in advance
that I'd be talking
about a KISS biopic today?
-No. Just took a chance.
I wear KISS makeup to work
about half the time.
-All right. Well, you --
you can't wear that
during the show.
-Ugh.
Fine.
You never support me, anyway.
-Oh, come on.
I -- Thanks, buddy.
I-I appreciate it.
-Oh, you know what?
It's me. I'm sorry...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Get this --
starting on May 1st,
topless clubs in Las Vegas
are officially allowed
to reopen.
[ Scattered cheers ]
Whew!
Just in time for Mother's Day,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
If you're excited
about topless clubs reopening,
I'm assuming
it was a long quarantine.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this --
Nathan's is offering
5-cent hot dogs at Coney Island
this summer
for the first time in 100 years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Applause ]
Customers were like,
"Uh, I'd actually feel better
if you charged more."
[ Laughter ]
5-cent hot dogs?
I'd rather get
5-cent LASIK eye surgery.
[ Laughter ]
What?
Eating a 5-cent hot dog
is as safe
as taking home a mattress
on the street that says, "Free."
[ Laughter ]
"Seems like a good deal."
-"Hey. Yeah."
-"Let's take it
back to the house."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I saw that Martha Stewart
just announced
the release
of her 99th cookbook.
-Whoo!
-Oh.
-99.
At this point,
the recipes are just...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Rude.
-It says, "Leave me alone,"
in the book.
-Wow.
Very rude for a cookbook.
-She would never.
Did you guys hear about this?
An explosion
at a gender-reveal party --
my gosh --
in New Hampshire
was so powerful that it damaged
[Chuckling] nearby homes
and was felt in other states.
-What?
Now, what's up with
these gender-reveal parties?
-Like...
-[ Laughs ]
After the explosion,
everyone was like,
"It's a...lawsuit!"
[ Laughter ]
What is going on
with these things?
-It's crazy.
-Yeah.
They're supposed to reveal
the gender of the baby,
not the IQ of the parent.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, this made me laugh --
a man in Taiwan
is making news for finding
an interesting way
to get some extra time off
from work.
Listen to this story.
-A man in Taiwan found
a creative way
to get an extended vacation
from work.
He initially got married
last April.
He was given eight days off.
At the end of his leave,
he divorced his wife
and planned to remarry her
the next day.
And he did this whole process
not once, not twice,
but three times.
-[ Laughing ] Wow.
Wow! Yeah.
His boss knew something was up
when he got a letter
that said...
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
a woman here in New York City
came home to her apartment
and found an unexpected visitor.
Watch this.
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
-What?!
-Wow. I didn't even know
New York City pigeons laid eggs.
[ Laughter ]
I thought they were just rats
that earned their wings.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry, though --
the pigeon's gone,
and this is
no relation at all --
I just want to remind everyone
about Nathan's 5-cent hot dogs
this summer on Coney Island.
Happy summer, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]